もう年末うんもう年末あ今日は外したそうですという2020年今年も始雪の動画を見
て下さった皆様本当にありがとうございましたそしてお仕事学校
いろいろ火事本当に今年は
マーチでおつかれさまでしたもういろんなことがあったでしょう感染症が流行って本当
にいろんな人の生活が一変して僕の周りでもいろんな人が苦しんでて世界的に非常に
苦しい1年だったと思うんですけれども
まあそれも今日でおしまいでございます
本当に皆さんよく今年1年頑張ったと自分を褒めてあげてください
まぁ僕も youtube どんな1年だったかというとチャンネル登録数が900万
に行ったっていうすごい額う
キレイ術基準でしたねあとは毎日投稿者寝ましたねヒカキンさんからフィッシャーズと
彼も僕も全然は言ったしてないようになって
なんか彼にショートが増えたかもしれないけどか慌ただしくも皆さんのおかげでこう
やっているチューブを仕事にさせていただいております本当にありがとうございます
まあていければ毎年通り総集編なんですけどもやっぱ毎日動画出さないとバット少なく
なったんで結構見やすいかも知れませんかどうぞ
え私
肇社長は
1年間
腹筋
[音楽]
2お願いします
ああああああ
[音楽]
goo
ああああああ
dee
tai
多分 en
[音楽]
をへ
ran
そりゃあ平買っていっ
と思います
ああああああ
さああっ韓方まり弾けるにアレン
バズー大丈夫ズバリ少し口に運んだ
分泌とグラフィックべくパンケーキ your a
ああああああああ
ああああああああいざん
田渕やばいやばいよねもいれる多い
[音楽]
いやほんと行ける所だろうカラー
goo
うわぁ来年から大学生なんだけど際に撮るのって言って子だけなんですよと言います
[音楽]
電気ですか原じゃあなんでだよ
いやジョブペンネームここはシュート泣かなきゃいけない東へから打っていきますこれ
で終わります素晴らしいシュート
ウール am
[音楽]
なくなりましたんってすごいです魔法陣を展開されてほしいですねっ
塩記述調整抗生剤便のささやき
far
ええええええ
ウェーブがハワイ1塁側でお代わりを変えよ方へ
6 p チーズご飯でございます
パーク前に座って何巻まで病気ています
ポッチクーラーってくるこっちへ来るでああ
これぞよず前なええええっ
par
あんだか自分だぜくすライブという事を忘れてきたね
ええええええ
花王骨著2画面単通路でホラー
ばっっ
多分ん
あ護衛者以後のものシーターフォールのために延伸してしまったのです
ぜひこっちゃえっすがー員が乗っ度やゲイ
[音楽]
ぶううううううっ
あ705万53104 a
earth
ben wong kar
ni
ana
1で目が3つになっつってるよしかも2つ等でも満足曲を始めている
ok ですわー
ana ああああ
ああああああああああああっ
そしてスペシャルゲストをご用意しておりますどうぞ
アリーのがもうフェアリーがもう自然界最長最近だと結構目立ち期ちびでを期してみれ
ローマっ
カーン氏おっ
[音楽]
まあおふざけなまたぁあああああああ
アレアレだのブサイクじゃねぇ
[音楽]
種類も食前は砂定説の枯れない
異種トレン
[音楽]
以来ああ
ん
おおぉ
[音楽]
をもう抜かれているが1匹だけの秘密の選手といっしょを貸してくれる優しい
シェーパーと元いる
これ仲良く2人でバーデーだけでいい姉ショッ
立ってるとですねサーん南蛮ンな気持ち多くなってきて不思議なふわふわ感に襲われて
おっおおっ
見てるなぁドイツなんか紐がちょっと切りかかってるみたいなそんな事は始めるのか
見てますか
美味しいですよあああああ
ni
ai
ああああああ
彼らが使え
nod みんなを先ほど水着
言いだぞ w
rar
[音楽]
ん
トランスまで番1勝負だ
ええええええ
mar ter
[音楽]
道央場所ですよなんせ
ちょっと聞き取りづらいだ
a
[音楽]
0値段これ誰バッハ
声
[音楽]
何ん
ああああああ
rar
すごい
ルーうわぁ凄い凄い
kounan えっ
[音楽]
こののファンの方にはもう歌えねぇ
入ってるけどいかがだったでしょうか2020年の外れ社長
まあいやもうねんじゃねぇ青人勢企画度が結構中ミスなんですよ
別に何か言うことじゃないんですけどオクラ動画が多くて実は結構萎えた一年あったん
ですけどまぁこう
英語で体って限られた環境状況ですずぶんができることをやっていくしかないと思うの
で
いっ
ならず事態が収束してまたみんなで会える1勝を目指したいと思います
2021年もよろしくお願いしまーす
広い私よええ
ブーブーブーブー
いっ